what is the battle of armageddon is it literal and
what are gog and magog the matter of armageddon is
literal in the sense that there will be a struggle
between good and evil there won't be bombs going
off and bullets flying and land mines no nothing
of the sort this is a spiritual battle as it was
when christ threw satan out of heaven many many
many many many years ago so it is a literal battle
but not fought with the weapons that we are
familiar with it is essentially a spiritual battle
the battle of armageddon takes its name from the
city of megiddo in the middle east which is called
the plain of s drailon where a lot of significant
battles were fought in the old testament
perhaps the most significant is found in
judges chapter four where the israelites
fought the canaanites and the israelite leader
was barack and he wouldn't he didn't want to
fight but the prophetess or the judge a
deborah told him he said if you go with me
i'm going so she said i'll go with you and
they went and the bible says in judges 4 16
that all the canaanites not not one man
was left a total victory and so this is
the way the victory will be for christ in
the battle of armageddon the forces of good
led by christ will crush the forces of evil led by
satan that's a literal spiritual battle fighting
which still still earth it is a literal spiritual
battle right now you and i from day to day
we go through spiritual battles we can see the
enemy but it is literal we can see the enemy
the battle of armageddon is a battle between the
forces of good and righteousness led by christ
those who have respected the law of god and
the forces of rebellion led by the devil
and leading those who have chosen to ignore
the law of god yes the weapons of our warfare
aren't carnal but they're mighty through god so
in that time we'll have to stay on our knees we
have to pray we have to fast we have to spite
fight spiritually that's no joke my sister we
really have to do that yes even in today's day
and age we don't gotta wait but we have to learn
now especially in today's day and age especially
since we're about to enter a time of trouble since
such as the world has never seen especially in
this day and age we have to be spiritually alert
yes
you